hey
i'm kurt davina and this is remember
when the show about old stories in
gaming history
told with new perspectives and today
we're talking about
halo microsoft's crowning franchise a
series that has changed
console shooters forever and became the
face of the xbox brand
except it almost didn't happen that way
at all
halo wasn't revealed to the world by mr
microsoft man himself bill gates but
instead
steve jobs and it wasn't an e3 2001
but actually mac world 1999
and it wasn't even supposed to be a
first person shooter so
considering that halo is one of the most
culturally impactful and successful
video game franchises
ever made spawning dozens of books toys
almost a movie
but definitely a tv show six sequels
and spin-off games it's kind of wild to
think that the halo we know today
may have been a whole lot different
now in order to unpack all this we need
to go back
29 years ago where pc gaming was
in a much different place so i made a
timeline
a very detailed accurate timeline
if you're alive in the 90s like me
that's me
here and have any memory of playing
games on a computer
there's a very high chance that it was
on a windows pc
but if your family had a mac well this
was a
lonely place to be a gamer and the
absence of games
was actually deliberate in this issue of
computer gaming world from 1990 it is
cited that developers asked apple for
joystick support
which in response an executive said
quote no
then people will think this is a game
machine so naturally developers flocked
to windows where there wasn't some sort
of stigma about making
and playing games however this left an
untapped demographic for mac users and
a far less saturated place for games and
one studio was willing to try and still
make games
for apple's non-gaming machine
bungie prior to joining bungie i had
graduated from
college as a graphic designer at that
time we were exclusively working on mac
there were very few games
to play especially multiplayer games but
there was this one that we played
all the time and that was marathon made
by bungie and it was really
fantastic way to you know connect
designers from one studio to another and
just kind of
glued us all together in a way that
excited me enough about
the potential with the gaming industry
bungie was started in 1991 by two
young college students alex serapin and
jason jones and the team chose to focus
solely on making net games
just because it was less crowded than
windows what followed was a couple games
with some modest success like
operation desert storm or pathways to
darkness but
it was marathon that was bungie's big
breakout success
or better known as max answer
to doom at that time bungie was real
small so it was a very intimate kind of
affair but yeah
like marathon and then myth i i was just
i was so excited about
uh this this notion of what we could do
with video games and
we would build games for the mac and and
they were going to be awesome marathons
follow-up myth
equally proved to be a success which
gave jason jones the leeway to finally
start working on his next
big project which he called monkey nuts
was it actually codenamed monkey nuts at
first
yes it was in fact codenamed monkey nuts
it went through a few iterations as it
went from stage to stage
and uh monkey nuts was one of them that
uh
yeah you could tell we were a real
mature group of young guys in our 20s
making games
in some ways if you take marathon an
epic first-person shooter and combine it
with
myths terrain-focused real-time strategy
you have the foundation for
what initially was monkey i mean uh
halo yeah our very first steps in
developing the game
initially uh the goal was to make it
very similar to myth
the sci-fi skinning of this new universe
we were creating
i remember jason and i working on
building our first
3d characters the first iteration of
this little soldier character we called
the super soldier
we began kind of flushing out the very
early foundation
of the halo universe the very early
stages of the covenant
and the forerunners at that time the
forerunners were an
actual physical entity on the
battlefield as well
one of our programmers uh charlie who
is now the president of bungie he
started programming in some physics for
the warthog how he would drive over the
cab the terrain and jump over jumps and
it got so interesting to us we were
looking at the simulation as we were
point and clicking these things around
on the map
and we're saying holy crap this looks so
interesting
why aren't we controlling them ourselves
and doing this ourselves
that would be far more fun wouldn't it
and
that's when we decided to pivot
completely and
start developing a third person action
game
the game hadn't yet been fully realized
it didn't even have an official title
but it was already being considered
max killer app and it got the attention
of a certain turtleneck wearing
executive which brings us to
the grand revealed halo at
act world we are starting to see some
great games come back to the map
but this is one of the coolest i've ever
seen halo is the name of this game
and we're going to see for the first
time halo welcome
everything you're about to see is being
rendered in real time
on a macintosh i had been working on
this game for
about a year and a half or two our team
was still small around 10 people
we were pretty nervous about showing
something off
but we were able to orchestrate a real
simple narrative and have our early
version
of the master chief running around our
early versions of the warthog
and the elites and ghosts and banshees
and all these things flying through this
beautiful open world with a colorful sky
and the rain rising up into the horizon
and even delving into the forerunner
underground facility
where there were holographic elements
flying around we were so excited about
what we were creating thinking it looked
amazing at that time and if i look at it
now in retrospect
it's it looks like something that might
my children would be able to build
with guys like joe and jason to get up
on stage
with steve jobs to present our very
earliest vision of halo was just
exhilarating for us as a studio
buzz began to grow around halo but
behind closed curtains and despite being
a successful mac developer
bungie was actually struggling to keep
the lights on so
how was bungie in financial trouble well
it could be in part to a very expensive
near 1 million dollar recall
of myth 2 which contained a bug that
wiped the user's computer
if they uninstalled it prior internet
updates and day one patches
bungie had to get all the games back
make new discs
replace previous discs and then send
them back out so in large part due to
that
very expensive pr mistake bungie started
shopping itself
around seeking to be purchased enter
microsoft microsoft had its new sleek
black plastic cinder block on the way
and was in need
for content so microsoft decided to
pinch right from steve
jobs apple tree
yeah and like that bungie uprooted moved
to seattle and was tasked with shifting
gears on halo
yet again because microsoft wanted a
first person
shooter for its new console and in the
most cliche
way imaginable the rest really is
history it got sequels
and spin-offs sold millions upon
millions of copies and first person
shooters and consoles
have never been the same since
[Applause]
[Music]
but what if
halo never actually came out on the xbox
and
was a mac exclusive
[Music]
just for a moment let's imagine a world
as though halo never revolutionized
console shooters and instead came out
the way
it was initially intended would it have
even been
an fps if we had just stayed on the mac
we probably would have stayed within the
myth engine
we probably would have continued to
develop this game as an
open world until we figured out some of
the
pretty significant barriers of what that
would have presented to us
and and started scoping it back it
probably would have
been a really cool game but i'm not sure
it would have had the outreach
that we had uh given the move we made it
probably would have stayed through
person which would have changed the
aiming mechanics the
uh the overall feel of the uh the design
um of the game in general um all of
those core mechanics would have
really been dramatically different and
so it's it's hard to imagine
what it really could have turned into
could you imagine the uh
the next imac would just be this giant
green
uh helmet like thing with an orange
screen and a visor over it and
to protect from the sunshine outside and
yeah i
probably would have there would have
been weird things like that i'm sure
i mean we did get tons of halo themed
xboxes so it's not
that far-fetched to assume that maybe
apple would do
a themed imac i mean who knows apple did
release
a video game console back in 1996 which
was
an utter disaster but maybe they would
have released another one
hopefully not called the pip apple tv
would have had a halo tv show apple
arcade would have likely launched with a
halo ios game and most recently apple
put a ban on microsoft's
xcloud like their game streaming thing
in this case
we probably would have been streaming
halo to our phones that is even if
xcloud
would have existed what would have xbox
been like in this alternate reality
we what would xbox live be like what
would first person shooters be like
without this
[Music]
now imagining all this is arbitrary
i know but i do think there's value in
at least entertaining the what-if
scenarios of things
that could have been halo has had a
staggering
impact on the culture of games and the
identity of many gamers
what would a world have been like if we
didn't have that video of a bunch of
atlas and boys coming together
to sing a soundtrack in a bathroom
[Music]
that's a world i don't want to live in
and even still it did eventually come to
mac os
and pc and even returned to its roots as
rts
with halo wars now will halo
revolutionize games
again that timeline has yet to be
written
but one thing's for sure is that its
legacy and what's done to games
is surely set in stone
if you've made it this far thank you
very much
for watching this episode of remember
when i hope you enjoyed it now if you're
new here thanks for coming by
as well we have a bunch of episodes that
we've done some on consoles
one on resident evil another on street
fighter and the link to that and the
playlist will be in the description
below so yeah um i'm kurt and davina by
the
way
pleasure to meet you if we haven't
already been acquainted and um
that's really about it hope you're doing
well be well stay safe
okay all right see you later